our shout out tonight for a remarkable
piece of investigative journalism that
has already had huge impact on the lives
and health of schoolchildren in
Philadelphia it was news that shocked
the city dangerous levels of mold lead
asbestos inside more than a dozen
Philadelphia schools all the result of a
two-year long project called toxic city
SiC schools by the Philadelphia Inquirer
and two enterprising reporters I'm Wendy
Ruderman on the reporter for the
Philadelphia Inquirer and I'm Barbara
Laker I'm a reporter also for the
Philadelphia Enquirer after the scandal
of dangerous lead levels in the drinking
water in Flint Michigan the two
reporters wanted to know what the story
was in Philadelphia we wanted to take a
look at Philadelphia's numbers and see
in children in Philadelphia were being
exposed to lead and we learned that kids
in Philadelphia were actually exposed to
lead and had lead poisoning at far
higher rates than in Flint Michigan and
so they looked first at homes and
landlords then playgrounds and finally
school we were actually really shocked
how bad that conditions were in the
schools but it took months of work to
prove it and a lot of stealth finding
teachers to conduct tests inside the
school teachers were very reluctant they
were afraid of retribution from the
school district but ultimately we did
get 26 teacher to help us do the testing
and 19 of the most rundown schools the
reporters could not go into schools
themselves to avoid being accused of
trespassing and it was all very
hush-hush as the equipment and test
results were passed back and forth it
was almost like it was like a drug deal
or something that was kind of funny and
crazy but they wouldn't hand us these
little vials filled with dose wipes and
then we would take them over to the lab
the results made headlines investigation
teachers at a Philadelphia K through 8
school have just about had and students
at one of the schools even wrote letters
to local officials we need funding for
very school it's like the school is
falling apart
dear state senator Vincent use every day
I go to school I feel like I'm in a
prison or a junkyard
the school can fire it down any time so
our doors are broken broken computers
and leaking heaters we had one little
boy Dean Fagin he was a first grader in
a school and he was sitting at his desk
trying to learn and there was a ton of
lead paint on the ceiling above his desk
and it fell on his desk and on the floor
beside his desk and he was scared that
he'd get in trouble having a messy desk
and he thought he'd also the teacher
would be mad at him if he got up to put
it in the trashcan so we ate the lead
paint chips on his desk and he ended up
having a lead level of like 46 which is
I mean off-the-charts high he was
hospitalized for three days and nights
and he was left the reporters say with
serious learning disabilities this
afternoon the mayor and other city
leaders visited a middle school the
story finally got the attention of
school officials who at first had been
highly critical of the reporter's
efforts the testing methodology that was
employed by the reporters we have
already come out and been very clear
that we don't agree with that but under
public pressure the schools launched a
massive 15 million dollar cleanup
campaign at the seven schools named by
the Philadelphia Enquirer as having the
worst conditions but that sort of raises
questions about all the schools that we
didn't get into and we couldn't get
teachers to test or we just you know
it's just it's just so vast it was a big
commitment from our newsroom and it
involved pretty much the whole staff and
yes my myself and Barbara and Dylan
Purcell who helped us do a lot of the
data analysis of maintenance Long's
ultimately our job is to expose
something that's wrong and shed light on
it and then empower people with
knowledge and then on top of that and
the community to actually pick up the
ball and have conversations that make
change and that's what's happening here
in Philly so our shout out to Wendy
Ruderman and Barbara Laker and their
investigations editor Jim Neff and the
Philadelphia Inquirer for clearing the
path for this huge undertaking
investigative reporting at its very best
that's our program for tonight
thanks for joining us we'll see you
again here next week good night